hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
another aldo jones our homeboy alto
weird trailer go subscribe to this guy's
patreon page and his youtube channel
while you're at it check out our far
from home reaction got a amusing 45
second intro sketch so let's get to it
shall we synchronize old context of that
[Music]
no Texas will holder dude this one's
crazy
it was crazy Aldo
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
ha
yeah
Wow trying to get to a billion you do it
[Music]
you go Anton Blake Cox oh wow guys go to
his patron page soon as you can
dargah long dude all these people made
it possible reacting good for you guys
[Music]
[Music]
what is this huh
I don't know he credited it in the thing
Aldo you have taken your energy levels
to a whole new level on this one buddy
this was insane the kinetic energy from
beginning to end just this little
snippets and sketches like every second
of this versus madcap I loved it was the
do this one's crazy clearly he used the
word first you took every single whim
that came to your mind and just put a
joke on this trailer this is one of the
most kinetic in terms of just how
quickly a new joke or a new twist will
arise because it's also like twists this
trailer up pretty hard to you know Aldo
Jones tributes of course and the
reoccurring jokes of bully Maguire the
oh yeah Mark Ruffalo which because of
you I actually looked at that actual
interview have you seen that interview I
have not seen it all the way he's
talking about how it was the way Robert
Downey jr. introduced him on stage and I
think at a comic-con convention it's in
reprising the role or something like
that that's like a joke yes because it
wasn't Edward Norton so that's what he's
referring to yeah there was something
that got me like really thinking about
it with Aunt May and happy when you did
your version here man that context would
feel a whole lot different a future was
an old lady huh yeah it would imply that
happy is into a different kind of woman
yes funny for very different reasons I
just slept together pretty well together
pretty well man she is the OG an may
have the cinema there's like a lot of
like really cool jokes that follow up
one another you for example with a
briefcase which in the trailers is
property Uncle Ben so this is a property
of Ned Flanders and it's super quicker
than the very next shot you see Ned
Flanders in the airport yeah I think
it's cool it's appropriate because of
when you watch movie like into the
spider-verse
that's a movie that you'll get more from
and notice little things the second time
you watch it so I went back to watch it
a few days later of course there's like
little things in the background I didn't
notice before so if you like to go
really crazy with this one
works is even there's such quick moments
like slowing this down right now after
the airport scene whether in the plane I
didn't even notice this hill right this
moment when Tom all lists up the window
you got Tobey Maguire Tom Holland Andrew
Garfield an Italian spider-man all right
I love Italian spider-man made it into
this trailer company well what was a
real standout moment but I love the ones
that feel like kind of a spider-verse
movie when it's just so brief just a
little snippet of a moment you know yeah
you know Aldo Jones loves that hides
stuff for you to go find and pick out
man and a bit with net was extremely
different well I always get tickled when
people make Nick Fury more Sam Jackson
Lee than he actually I always say your
steer videos you could rewatch them and
get more from but this one about like 30
to 40 seconds into it I was like this
lends itself to such rewatch ability
from beginning to end and that's so cool
you can compose just a YouTube video for
that man seriously congrats man this is
amazing your costume is amazing the only
thing missing I think only because it's
not out on blu-ray yet that's the thing
it's not is you know including the
spider-verse characters other than that
but I feel like you can do for the next
one this is very so crazy because
something about this maybe go after
spider-verse this feels like this really
was sort of a compliment to my world
well yeah as it takes that instinct of
life what's the reference I can pull
from this moment or that moment and it
seems like you yeah you really didn't
restrict yourself to you know being
beholden to the structure of this
trailer as much as yeah just taking
every opportunity to squeeze another
delicious morsel referential goodness I
also like how he took moments of just
Tom Holland and threw it in here if he
was obviously when he's in British
accent like is just from like an
interview resumption you know well
that's I mean that's perfect cuz he's
gotten so good like stitching heads onto
things and making you almost wonder you
know like how which parts of this are
doctored how and from where yeah I love
this one I really I really did love this
one now
yeah I gotta be one of my top ones for
sure before we wrap this video up I
let's give a patron today shots a man
named Jake Stewart Jake my man who's
been pledged to us for quite some time
he actually found us when I went on
movie fights last year for best action
hero of all time go check that episode I
just wanted to plug that really quick
yeah so Jake my homeboy you know he
comes from a small town only about like
50 people live there it's really tiny
two buildings it's important a reason
yeah it's really rule it's really sad
actually but Jake unfortunately dishes
out his hard-earned pennies that he
gathers from being a homeless guy and
uses it to go towards our patreon page
so I really appreciate that dude looked
up your name your name means God is
gracious which is beautiful but you know
what's not gracious the fact that the
last time I gave you a shout-out I sent
you a link to it and I message you
asking if you got it and even though
you're still pledged to our patreon page
you haven't messaged me back and it's
been a few weeks so that is not
courteous that is not gracious I don't
know what your problem is
maybe your town is out of Internet
service due to the fact that you live in
the middle of nowhere the whole town
gets five gigabytes a month split
between all 50 people that makes sense
as long as you stay pledges we're cool
if you have a hard time accessing the
Internet to remove your card from the
reoccurring charges that's way better
rule we're cool with that so thank you
for everything buddy thanks Jase do you
guys can subscribe the reject nation
click that notification bell and we'll
catch on the flippity flippity flip
subscribe to Aldo